(applause)
- Thank you, brother.
One last thing before he
dives in, we want to do a little
#AskGaryVee with him.
Gary, we're gonna have to
look at this screen here.
We have our own little GaryVee
thing and unfortunately we moved
these screens so it's going
to be a little hard to see.
But if you guys can put up
the #AskGaryVee card
collector edition,
this would be great.
Card collector challenge.
Gary talks a lot about how he's
a baseball card guy, he was in
the past and so when I
interviewed him in his office in
the fish bowl there, when
I was talking it was cool.
There was things going
around, he was looking around.
I'm like, it was okay, okay,
Keith, Sean are
here, this is great.
And then I said, "Let's
talk about baseball cards."
His antennas went way up.
He got super excited and dialed
in so let's just go into
this challenge, shall we?
Gary, the very first challenge,
let's turn Gary's mic on.
Check, check.
There he is.
- Hey. Great Jets hat.
I'm pumped.
- Here we go.
Very first question is this
what box does this
maker belong to?
- Donruss?
- [Sean] Woo!
- What?
(cheers and applause)
Don't sleep on my skills.
- Question number two--
- Fuck, I'm so
pumped I got that right.
- What is the name can you
see this one over there?
- Go ahead.
Oh fuck, I have no idea who the
guy Nolan Ryan shared
his rookie card with.
Koosman?
- Koosman is right!
- What? What? What?
(audience laughter
and applause)
Holy shit.
- Question number three--
- I hate this fucking guy.
(audience laughter)
- What year and make is
this basketball card?
- '90 Fleer.
(Sean laughs)
- Oh my god, yes.
- Guys, guys you all know me.
This is the only thing I gave a
fuck about for
eight years of my life.
Think about that much intensity
deployed against one
little narrow thing.
- Next question,
we only have a couple more.
Next question, whose
rookie card is this?
- Ernie Banks?
- [Sean] Yes!
Ernie Banks.
(applause)
- [Sean] Next question, this is
a Donruss blank rookie card.
- Rated Rookie.
- [Sean] Rated
Rookie is correct.
And we have one more
what year and
make is this card?
'80 Topps.
- [Sean] '80-what?
- I got it wrong.
I got a wrong 'cause
I thought it was '80,
oh this is '83.
- [Sean] '83 Topps.
- Yep.
- [Sean] One last question, and
I'm super impressed because
I was card collector,
who is this player?
- Roberto Clemente.
- And the winner is
Roberto Clemente. Good job.
(cheers and applause)
Gary, the stage
is yours, my man.
I'm gonna be so upset about that
Ozzie Smith fuck up for
the rest of the night.
(laughter)
Thanks for having me.
So mainly to be very honest with
you I'd really prefer to do Q&amp;A
once I saw the two mics up
there, I thought wow this is
great so feel free.
I'd like to spend most of the 45
minutes to an hour to do Q&amp;A.
Feel free to like
start lining up now.
I'm gonna pontificate
about a couple things.
Number one, as I caught the
end of Sean's talk I think it's
really interesting to
talk about hustle and magic.
As you sit here in the audience
I ask myself what's practical?
What's practical?
Can you go home and
create more magic?
I'm not sure, right?
I think we can talk
about that a little bit.
I think it has a lot to
do with self-awareness.
I think a lot of you in this
room want to be something
instead of reverse
engineer what you actually are.
But can you really go home and
become Sean and have that level
of charisma and have that?
I don't know, I've always felt
that talent could be honed, you
could maximize, by the way,
your kicks are phenomenal.
I think you can
maximize your talent.
I feel like I have a certain
amount of basketball
talent in my body.
Sure, I can play every day but
can I really get to that extreme
level where I could be
on a basketball card.
Just punchline,
the answer is no.
I do not believe that you sit
here, you fly into Vegas you sit
up here and listen to all these
great speakers, a lot of my
homies have spoke earlier and
I don't think you go
home and scale magic.
And so I love Sean with all my
heart but here's one thing I can
promise you, you can all
go home and hustle more.
And the reason I push hustle so
much is because it feels like
the most fuckin' controllable
thing to change the outcome of
what disappoints you.
(applause)
It's just the most
controllable thing.
I don't know how, there's gonna
be a lot of stuff that people
are gonna talk about
during this weekend.
I don't know, yes, yes
I think you should all go home
and become dramatically
more charismatic.
I think you should do that.
How?
And so I think the answer to
how was actually in a
very interesting place.
I think the thing that separates
individuals from winning
is self-awareness.
I really do.
If I can get across anything
in today's talk it's how do
I create some level of
permission for you to start
feeling more comfortable in your
own skin in a world where your
mom and dad didn't
do that for you,
in a world where neighborhood
didn't do that for you,
in a world where the coolest kid
in high school didn't
do that for you,
in a world where
America makes
trillions of dollars in
industries telling you what you
suck shit at so you spend money
on fixing it versus doing what
is fundamentally the reason
I know I get the stand here on
stage which is you're right,
Sean, I really don't give a fuck
about what anybody thinks in the
same way Rush and Howard think.
The only difference is, and
I don't know those guys,
is I equally really give a
shit about what you think.
And I think if you understand
what I mean by that you can
start really tapping through.
I will not live my life based on
what you want me to or whatever
the current
politically correct POV is.
Every day, and I know a lot of
you know who I am, I get emails
yelling at me for my
work life balance.
I also know that as much love
as that and, I look at that as
love, people email me I don't
think they're trying
to hurt my feelings.
I think you're telling me things
that maybe happened to them.
Hey, I have kids in college now.
I regret not
spending time with them.
You're going to
and I don't get mad.
I just know that that
person doesn't know me.
I know that person
doesn't know me.
My friends, we're living
in a width world
not a depth world.
There's plenty of my friends
that critique my work life
balance that come home, go
downstairs into their man cave,
drink four Budweisers
and go to sleep.
I don't view them as
spending quality time
with their children.
(applause)
And so, I'm also very
comfortable in my losses.
I'm comfortable in
the bed that I made
and thus I sleep in it.
I'm not perfect.
I plan on making mistakes.
Big ones.
I can't wait 'til I have
to apologize to America.
It's how we roll.
We're humans, right?
The fact of the matter is I'm
just comfortable in my intent
I'm comfortable in
a lot of things.
I, for example, I'm comfortable
in that most of the decisions
that I've made in my life over
the last 15 to 20 years have
been far more predicated on
my legacy than anything else.
I've left a lot of money on the
table over last 10 years 'cause
I care about my legacy.
I want all of you to
show up to my funeral.
However, I know that
I love to reassess.
Let me explain.
This year David Bowie, Prince,
very famous people
have passed away.
I've been taken aback by the
fact that America cares
for about 20 hours.
And I've said, "My God, these
are really famous fuckers."
Right?
And we are living in such a
fast-paced world, we're moving
on so much quicker and I've
started saying to myself,
"Hmmm, should care so
much about my legacy?"
That even if I crush it all the
way through if everybody shows
up it's only got
a 24 hour window.
Should I care
about my inner circle?
about my outer circle?
I think the biggest thing that
I'm starting to feel, knowing a
lot of you have consumed a lot
of my content, something that
I don't think I've been sharing
a lot that I'd like to today,
tonight to bring you guys value,
to have you hear something
a little bit different,
I'm not scared to
fundamentally change
my life completely.
I am thrilled for making a
video that says fuck hustle.
Thrilled to say this is my last
video for 24 months, I'm going
on a beach, see you in 2029.
See what happens is when you get
real comfortable with yourself
you don't even care about how
you established your narrative,
you're willing to break it
because I just don't care about
the repercussions because at
that moment I am comfortable in
my decision and my intent.
And let me promise you
the quickest way to win.
And I don't mean
money, I mean win.
Playing in a way that feels
right to you before it feels
right to anybody
else around you.
And I promise you,
and I promise
you that the
majority of you are not.
It's just the way it is.
I don't really know, it's ironic
my wife plays the same game but
I really, my mom maybe, it's
stunning to me how few people
play it purely that way.
It's incredible how we are
affected by the five or six
closest people to us.
It is incredible to how many
people here in this room right
now that the singular
unlock to dramatic more success
emotionally, financially and
every other thing you can think
of is actually predicated on
them eliminating one person in
their inner circle, normally a
family member that is a complete
negative driver and is the
cancer within ecosystem does not
allow you to be successful.
But that's tough.
Easy for me to say up here on
stage like kick your mom
outta your life, right?
(audience laughter)
But here's the punchline, it
doesn't make it any less true.
And so, you know, I don't know
like there's 1 million
things we could talk.
By the way, as you guys are
lining up for Q&amp;A which fires me
up, keep doing it, I'm thrilled
to answer questions in very
specific detail like how do you
make a Snapchat filter or go all
the way to what's magic and so--
(audience laughter)
and so it's always
fun to speak second.
That's been on my mind a lot.
The other thing that's been on
my mind a ton and I'll go little
more practical, a little less
foofy, here's the punchline
my friends, it's called
distribution of attention.
If you really want to understand
what's happening here all the
talks for the next four days
there's only two things that
matter your content and
how many people see it.
It's actually a singular binary
game of two things that matter:
your content and how
many people see it.
You can listen to all the people
that are gonna tell you how to
growth hack or get distributions
or big build lists or run
Facebook ads the best, you can
listen to all of that but the
shit that comes out of your
mouth or what you write on paper
sucks shit you will lose.
And the fact of the matter is
over 80% of the people sitting
here aren't talented or
interesting or differentiated
enough to achieve the
dollar amounts they want.
That is why I love hustle
because just like I only have so
much basketball DNA and skills
if I work really hard I could be
a really fun, solid average
pickup player and I have news
for some of you entrepreneurs
some of you are just nice and
average entrepreneurs.
That doesn't mean that you
shouldn't do it, that means that
you need to be self-aware that
if you never made money by the
time you were 25 years old in
your life and you never sold
shit you just might not
be a salesman. Got it?
This game is all
predicated on self-awareness.
The other thing it's
predicated on is truth.
The amount of people sitting in
this room and by the way let me,
let me define
sitting in this room.
When I say sitting in this room
I actually don't mean
the 300 of you.
I actually mean the market
so let me use that instead.
The amount of people in
the market that claim to be
something they are not because
what they're reverse engineering
is that's where the money is
is the biggest reason
so many people lose.
You just can't fake who you are.
You can't manufacture it.
You can't want it.
So many people in here want to
be business coaches and they've
never built a fuckin' business.
(applause)
Before you give me
business advice it'd be really
interesting to understand if you
ever made money besides
giving business advice.
And so, that intrigues me.
What's more interesting for
the youngsters in this room that
want to play that card is
actually documenting and
communicating the journey of
learning business 'cause
that's your truth.
I would tell you the people that
are gonna win are the ones that
are telling the truest story.
I'm only lucky and a lot of
people get mad at me
when I say lucky.
They really do because they
do know that I work hard and
there's always that
debate of luck and work.
And by the way, losers
love to throw out luck.
But I do think I'm lucky in the
fact that it is never been more
attractive or cooler to be an
entrepreneur than right now.
It's so weird.
I take selfies in the street
'cause I'm a businessman.
The reason I'm really winning is
'cause I was a businessman when
it wasn't cool.
When I was a loser in school
because I was getting D's and
F's and for everybody here 40
to 60 you know that that was the
only, your grades were the
narrative of how good you were
and what college you went to was
the narrative of how
good you were.
When I was getting D's and
F's yet making $2000 a weekend
selling baseball cards my
friends parents and my teachers
thought I was a loser.
If was making $2-3000 a weekend
right now as a 13-year-old in
school, I'd be the
coolest kid in high school.
I'd be the next Mark Zuckerberg.
I'm gonna be on Shark Tank one
day when I grow up and
everybody would've loved me.
That's why it's working for
me because I haven't wavered
regardless of what you
guys gave a fuck about.
And guess what,
entrepreneurship's not gonna be
cool one day soon too.
It might be five years from now,
it might be 10 years from now
when everybody looks down on
it because we should be caring
about something else I'm still
going to be
fucking selling shit.
(applause)
And so what I fear right
now is people trying to
mold into something around
whatever's convenient
right now or cool.
Like your friends that sold real
estate in the mid-2000 and then
were social media experts when
that market collapsed, you know,
that narrative I'm worried about
people that are following the
current trend instead of
following the only thing that
they actually are.
And that's who wins.
Who do we cherish and
who do we put on pedestal?
The people that from the get
punted everything else and went
full-pledged themselves.
LeBron didn't try to
become well-rounded young man.
He fuckin' played
basketball, all-in.
And that's who we look at.
Beyoncé, there's home videos
and Star Search and all
that she went all-in.
The people that we look at and
admire they put in the work from
the get regardless of what
they are because that's the only
thing they knew how to be and
I'm telling you right now the
best blueprint for your success
is to when you're done tonight
doing whatever the fuck you're
doing tonight to go in to your
hotel room, look yourself in the
mirror and ask yourself what's
the purest form of who I am
and build a fucking
thing around that.
That works.
(applause)
And whether it's cool
right now or whether it makes
the most money, do you think
that the best gamers in the
world right now 10 years
ago thought sitting in their
basement playing shooter games
was gonna make them
$10 million a year in e-sports?
Absolutely not.
When you are all-in on your shit
and we now live in a world where
the internet creates niche
communities around every fucking
thing you could ever imagine
that is an unbelievable blessing
to all of us that our
grandparents didn't have an
opportunity in and
so I just don't know.
I know a lot of you have
watched, a lot of you tweet
about this event, I looked
at your accounts,
people are chasing money.
I don't give a shit what you
guys say, now I'm talking to
this room most of you are
chasing fuckin' money and
you're gonna fuckin' lose.
And that's what
I hope you think about.
I hope you think about what
you are good at or
what are you really,
like what's the truest
essence of who you are because
those are the only two things
that create the upside
that people chase.
Because I know people with tons
of money that are sad as shit.
Right?
Because once you get something,
you want the other thing 'cause
it's always grass is
greener for all of us.
Right?
And so, great you
unlock a system.
You figured out how to do
something and you made some
bucks and then what?
And so, I'm telling
you two things either
talent, magic, which I do not
believe that you can manufacture
and/or what the fuck really
drives you for real and maybe it
won't make so much money right
now but when you deploy the
tactics of Snapchat
and Facebook ads
and AR and Pokémon GO and
whatever you deploy the tactics
against if you're deploying it
against fake shit that's being
built just to make a dollar,
you're gonna lose over time.
You're not gonna
be able to sustain.
You know why I hustle?
'Cause I fuckin' love it.
'Cause it's my oxygen.
You know why I hustle?
'Cause I don't even know
what the fuck else to do.
This is what I do.
If you really think about what
would you do every minute,
I'm retired now.
When people say they're gonna
retire and play golf
and surf, great.
I'm doing that now.
If you ask me to golf,
I'd rip my fuckin' arm
off I'd be so pissed.
(audience laughter)
I don't want to lay on a beach.
My head's turning.
I want to do shit.
I want to makes shit,
I want to talk to you.
I want to live.
This is how I live.
The people that hustle the
most are the happiest,
not the saddest.
Thank you.
(applause)
And you know what?
I'm even disgusted in
my own rah-rah just now.
In a practical level it is
practical to make money around
the thing that
interests you the most.
It's amazing.
Even though Crush It! is the
furthest thing from what I've
done in this space,
it's still the truest.
We live in an internet age where
niche are long and deep and you
can make money doing anything
and the thing you'll make the
most money on is the
thing you like the most.
Because if the thing you like
the most will allow you to work
the hardest and that will
be the variable of success.
And if you love it so much
you'll also research it more
'cause it's what you'd naturally
do anyway in your free time and
then you'll work harder
and then you make money.
Not you're a fuckin' life coach.
(audience laughter)
My man.
(applause)
What's your name?
- Alexander.
- [Gary] What's that?
- [Gary] Love it.
- Yeah, thank you Gary.
'Preciate it.
I was actually thinking about
creating a shirt
that says love it.
- [Gary] I can't hear shit.
Do I have bad ears?
What's that?
Yeah, alright, go ahead.
Go closer.
- How about now?
- [Gary] Way fuckin' better.
- There we go.
Once you find out who you are
and your strategy
and all of that--
- And real quick,--
- [Alexander] Go ahead.
- Most people fuckin' die before
they figure out you they are.
- [Alexander] This is true.
- Before we all go like now you
figured it out like real quick,
like before you figure out who
you, once you figure out who you
are just to give you a quick
punchline most of you
haven't gotten there yet.
Everybody's talking
about the tactics,
what about the religion?
Figure out who you are
especially at this young
of an age, challenge.
Challenge.
You've been told who you
are most of your life.
So going in that cocoon by
yourself and figuring it out and
blocking out everything that's
fuckin' hard so I'll answer your
question but I promise you
that's not so simple and
honestly that's what's happening
in this space too much.
Everybody's going to step two
and they haven't even
started on step one.
But go ahead.
- Thank you.
Spot on almost read my mind.
So what I'm talking about is,
you know, I truly believe that
I have found out who I am.
There's so many distractions,
so many Snapchats, I could watch
your Snapchat, I could watch
Ty's, I could watch everybody's
Snapchat, right?
So many distractions,
so many things.
My question is once you figure
out who you are and the vision
that you want to go, how do you
not stay, you're talking about
distribution of attention, how
do you go about staying on that
one, buying the Jets, whatever
the case may be for you?
- Dan Martell,
Sean, I never watched.
Sean's video spoof of Wine
Library TV which was phenomenal.
Let's clap it up for
the people that saw that.
It was fuckin' unbeli--
(applause)
That's literally,
Josh, right there.
All these cool homies,
I've never watched a
single piece of content.
I do not know a single word
that's ever come out of
Dan's fuckin' mouth.
I'm being dead serious.
I don't know.
How do I?
I've never been distracted
because I don't give a fuck what
anybody else is talking about.
I'm worried about my shit.
So if you're watching
everybody's snaps maybe you're
just not as driven as I am.
Maybe you don't care about
the things that I care about.
You know what I care about?
How everybody here reacts to
content so I spent all my time
reading all your comments.
I know everything you've said
about everything that I've done
because it's what I use to
figure out what
I'm gonna do next.
So instead of watching Sean's
point of view or fuckin' Wes who
loves to claim he's a better
speaker than me and
he fuckin' sucks.
(audience laughter)
Instead of doing that dumb shit,
I'm paying attention of when
I put out content how
do you guys actually
respond to it because that's
what makes a front leader.
I don't give a fuck about
Guy Kawasaki or Seth Godin's
point of view on Musical.ly.
I'm gonna go and use it, watch
how you guys react to it and
then that's why people listen
to me 'cause I do it first.
Because I don't even consume
anybody else's content so my
shit stays pure.
And my shit is pure because
you're actually giving me the
feedback 'cause you're
actually the audience.
So for me it's a
waste of fuckin' time.
I got time to watch the New
York Jets, that's my escapism.
Other than that,
family and this shit.
You're asking the wrong person
how to tune out other shit
'cause I don't care.
I haven't read
anybody's fuckin' book.
- That was a great answer.
- [Gary] It's the truth.
- Excellent.
- Thanks man.
- [Alexander] Thank you, Gary.
(applause)
- Thanks Alex.
By the way Alex, Alexander
by the way,
that's not necessarily
right for you.
There's a lot of people here
that do learn from watching
other people's shit.
My answer is I know myself.
I got D's and F's for a reason.
I'd love to read everybody's
wonderful books here,
I just won't retain any
of the information.
That's the ultimate
waste of fuckin' time.
If you're getting value by
watching others and that helps
your game, that's the
way you need to roll.
My game is based
on me knowing myself
and that's how I get good.
That's not disrespect to
all these wonderful people.
That's me understanding
how I learn. You got it.
(applause)
- Hey once again
it's great seeing you.
I saw you last year at Thrive.
- [Gary] How are you, man?
- It's great
talking to you then.
So one of the things that
I constantly see you always
mention on your on your podcast
or your Snapchats is definitely
always about the Uber deal being
something that you didn't get
into early on.
- The reason I bring up passing
on Uber twice is everybody
always wants me to talk about my
failures and the shit is I don't
know most of them.
That's one that I know
so I can bring it up.
- Got it.
And then as far as when it
goes in to that aspect with new
business opportunities what is
something that it is that you
see in either the founders or
the team that really make you
want to jump on it?
Uber was a somewhat of a pretty
big starting up but what was it,
what do you want to see in a
business before it, before you
see it take traction and
actually become involved in it?
- [Gary] What do I need to see
for me to invest in something?
- [Man] Yeah.
- It's normally intuition.
It has to be two things:
one, do I believe in the space.
So right now
I believe in meditation. Right?
So I think consumer
meditation is gonna be huge.
So then when I look at the
Headspace founders or the Calm
founders I need to
understand the jockey.
The only thing I do is
I always have a thesis.
Do I believe that Americans,
the world are gonna use
this product, right?
Are we gonna behave that way, do
I believe in these founders are
capable of being the
people that win in that game?
That it.
Nothing else.
I don't care your app has 7
billion people if I don't think
that's where the world's gonna
be in 3 to 4 years, I'm out.
And I don't care that I totally
believe in meditation if you
pitch it to me and you've never
sold anything and you no wins
on your table and I don't feel
anything intuitively, you have
no shot either so that's how
I basically make decisions.
- [Man] That makes sense.
And then as far as the founders
that you have worked with,
what is it that you
saw in them--
- No clue. Pure intuition.
It's like falling in love.
No idea.
- [Man] Makes sense.
- You know what I mean?
Fuckin' I don't know.
And founders come in and try
tell me shit they'll know I'll
hear, "I hustled
when I was a kid."
I'm like you're a fuckin' liar.
Next, you know it's intuition.
- [Man] Makes sense.
- Yeah.
- [Man] Perfect thanks.
- You got it.
(applause)
- [Susie] Hi Gary, I'm Susie.
- Hey Susie.
- Amazing to meet you.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- I first saw your
video back in 2010
the "Smurf It Up" one.
First of all, I want to say thank
you seriously from the bottom my
heart for like every single
video, everything that you do
I think I speak collectively for
everyone but you
inspire us so much.
- [Gary] Thank you so much.
- I also came from a
immigrant family
so I have much respect for
what your family has built,
you and your family,
right, however
I'm the only entrepreneur in
my family and so my question is
more about like I fought through
being like the black sheep and
doing something
different than everyone else.
- Why?
Because everybody wanted to
you to go to education and that
doctor, lawyers, horseshit.
- [Susie] Yeah.
Like do the safe thing, 'cause
they're terrified of doing
anything different.
I've fought through that.
Actually built up my business
in the last two years to--
- [Gary] Congrats.
- Thank you.
So the question becomes now how
do I up level my environment?
Right?
You were talking about how the
closest five people and maybe
eliminating one of them and that
was kind of interesting like how
do up level the people that
I spend time with and when
everyone around you operates in
a fear, you know what I mean,
how do up level that
whole environment?
- By going out and hanging
out with those kind of people.
- [Susie] How do you do that?
I work from home.
- Usually by taking
an Uber or a flight.
(audience laughter)
- [Susie] On a day-to-day basis.
- On a day-to-day basis, look
you can't control your family.
Right, my dad is one of the
most negative people I know.
If this whole room was filled
with water my dad would say this
is half glass empty.
My dad is super negative.
But I love my dad the most and
I spent time with him but, you
know, you can't control your
family, you can control your
friends so if you've got a
family that you think is
dragging you down or looks down
to what you're doing but you
love them and I love, my
sister is pretty negative.
I love her the most,
she's my baby sister.
I want to hang with
her all the time.
I would tell you that if you've
got a situation where all of
them, 'cause my mom super
positive, AJ's kind of more
neutral upper positive, I would
say that you've got to really be
very conscious of your friends
and what you have around you
beside your family and I would
go extreme positive
in that direction.
- [Susie] Okay.
- You know?
- [Susie] Yeah.
- You can only
control so much, right?
- [Susie] Right.
- I think we all have family,
it's impossible I think anybody
here zero family
members that are negative.
It's just my sister believed my
dad more than she believed my
mom thus she
became more negative.
Later in her life, very
recently, she's kind of flipped
and it's been game changing.
I think at some level you
choose, it's unbelievable the
level of disrespect I have
for everybody else's opinion.
(audience laughter)
I think that you should
consider to try that too.
I mean it and it's
very helpful for me.
By the way, I think
they're right a lot of times.
I don't think I'm always right
but I'm gonna tell you something
right now,
I'm always right for me.
And that's a very
subtle difference.
I'm not always right but
I'm 100% for me.
You know, I'm always
right for me and that's it.
And so I think it's the friends
and I think it's deploying a
little less credence and belief
in what your family is saying.
I would start
disrespecting them aggressively.
You got it.
(audience laughter and applause)
- [Man 2] Hey Gary,
how's it going?
- It's going super well, man.
How are you?
- Good.
Quick question, McGwire rookie
card, USA Olympic should I just
sell it or will the world forget
that he did steroids had the
home run record?
Ditch them or keep them?
- [Gary] The McGwire?
- Yeah, 'cause I got
a shit ton of 'em.
- [Gary] Did you get it graded?
- Yeah, it's mint.
I've got like five of them.
- I'd probably wait for him to,
like, it's kind of like all the
kids that were smart to sit on
their Pokémon cards
and just sell it now.
There's nothing good going on
with McGwire's brand right now,
I'd wait for the next bump
hopefully getting into the
Hall of Fame once everybody
forgets and liquidate then.
- Cool.
Can I ask my real question now?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- So I spent 16 years building a
very successful business and
I coach in that business
and I absolutely hate it.
It just drives me nuts.
- You have a business that
you spent six years on--
- [Man 2] 16.
- 16 that's super
successful but you hate it?
- [Man 2] But I hate it.
- Right, sounds
like a losing formula.
- Yeah, it sucks so I'm trying
to figure out how I can find out
you know what I coach very
niche in that market how I can
somehow test those skills
out to a broader market.
- So you just saying, it's a
little tough for me to hear,
I think got to go
to the ear doctor.
- [Man 2] Sorry about that.
Better?
- Did you say you're
coaching in that business?
- Yeah, I still work in the
business, I coach in that
business, I'm trying to figure
out if I can use those skills to
go broader instead of so deep
in a niche and I don't know what
platform to test that out on?
- [Gary] Your message you mean?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] As a gateway
drug to people,
you want to continue coach?
- [Man 2] Right.
- Are you sure about that?
- [Man 2] Yes, absolutely.
I enjoy the coaching aspect
of it, I'm just sick of this
particular industry.
- Well then, everywhere.
How do you communicate best?
Written, audio, video?
- [Man 2] Facebook,
video probably.
- Yeah, pollute your own waters.
Don't forget you're talking to a
dude that everybody thought was
the wine guy and had no idea
why the fuck he started
talking about business.
- [Man 2] Right.
- Right, so I think what people
do when they try to change is
they're worried that that
audience doesn't
want to hear that.
I'm sure 94% of my wine audience
didn't want to hear about social
media strategy but the 6% that
did was the base that
built the next thing.
- [Man 2] Cool, thank you.
- You're welcome.
(applause)
- Hi Gary.
- [Gary] Get into that mic.
- Okay, can you hear me?
- [Gary] Great.
- I've spent the last 10 years
building a household
staffing agency.
So I help families basically
around the world get
household staff.
And my question for you is I've
built my business where I'm kind
of at where I want to go to
the next level, and I've been
content with the
level I've been at.
- Real quick, when you say the
next level define to me what
that means for you.
- To hire, I guess
another one of me.
Somebody I'm going to pay
very well to also deal with the
clients and kind of manage them.
- Right, you don't
want it all on you.
- [Brooke] I don't
want it all on me.
I'm the one getting late night
calls and things like that I'm
trying to work on
the work-life balance.
- So why haven't
you done it so far?
- I had a really good assistant
for a long time handle it, and I
made the mistake, she got a
job offer at a startup doing
something she was really meant
to do, and since then I feel
like my assistants and people
working for me are
not at that level.
- [Gary] Did you say
earlier that you made a mistake?
- No.
- [Gary] I didn't hear right.
- I mean I make a
lot of mistakes.
- [Gary] Well, we all have.
But I thought you said you made
a mistake by maybe not matching
it, she just went on to
go do something else.
- [Brooke] Yeah, exactly.
- Okay.
- [Brooke] That was okay.
- And since then you haven't
been able to find
somebody as strong?
- Yeah, I think I stopped
looking for a while because the
clients when they would call
but they would just be
I want to talk to Brooke.
My clientele is a little
different in that they're all
millionaires and billionaires
and they don't respond to
typical marketing.
And my question for you is
kind of especially to double my
business and kind of
afford another one of me,
I was wondering if you
might have an idea or two.
Something maybe
I haven't thought of.
- You're saying to me, trying to
reach high net worth individuals
'cause you're staffing
services within their home.
To afford that
you gotta be rich.
- [Brooke] Yes.
- Your plan is that you want to
make more money, you want to get
more clients and then with
that money you get another you?
- [Brooke] Exactly.
- Let me ask you
question differently?
- [Brooke] Okay.
- Are you making enough money
right now to have
another one of you?
Because my intuition is you
can it's just you want to have a
certain amount of take-home or
spend that money on
some other stuff.
- [Brooke] Yeah, that's true.
I mean another one of
me but a cheaper, yeah.
Not super cheap.
Not like minimum wage but not
where they're super motivated.
- Your about to walk into a
hamster wheel that you're gonna
lose and most solo entrepreneurs
lose which is you're gonna try
to double revenue to deploy
against you because you want to
maintain your take-home income
and not invest in your business.
Tomorrow you should pay, you
should figure out how much money
you have to take, how much money
you take home, what's the least
you can take home and still live
your life and when I mean live
your life I mean pay your bills.
I think you should go hire
somebody have one year where you
didn't take the best vacations
you ever fuckin' took and you
didn't buy the best shit you
ever bought and then have that
person and then that person with
you will build up that revenue.
So many of you want both.
You want to take home money
to buy shit and you want your
business to grow.
Businesses grow when you
invest in your fuckin' business.
(applause)
Got it?
It's so common.
I see it every day.
The reason I built Wine Library
so fast is I was willing to as a
young man, when I was 28 years
old have a $40,000 a year salary
while all my other friends
had nice things I built a
$40 million business and
I wasn't reaping
any of the benefits
'cause every fucking penny was
going back in 'cause I was fine
to reap the benefits when
I was 29, 39 and 69, right?
I think what you need to do is
take your number all the way
down and be able to deploy that
against people because then the
combo of you guys will build the
top line revenue and you'll get
it back within 24 months.
- [Brooke] Yeah.
- Patience.
- [Brooke] Okay.
- Patience is the killer.
Patience is the absolute thing
that most people don't deploy in
to their business and
that's what limits their growth.
- [Brooke] Do you have like
one unique idea you can share?
- Yeah.
You should make Facebook video
and target it against high net
worth individuals
'cause they're there.
- [Brooke] Yeah, okay.
- Video.
- [Brooke] Video.
- Paint a picture to them.
- [Brooke] Okay.
- "Have you gone on a vacation
and wished somebody did a better
"job for you," right?
Like, "Are you pissed when
your housecleaner calls out,"--
- [Brooke] Housecleaner
doesn't show up?
- Yeah, got it?
- [Brooke] Yeah.
Thank you.
- Cool. You got it.
(applause)
- Hello Gary.
- [Gary] Hello.
- I love the show.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- My name is Rachel Luna,
RachelLuna.business,
'sup everybody?
Lately you have had some killer
guests on the show and I'm
wondering what's the strategy
behind who you're
bringing as guests?
- Super random.
- [Rachel] Wyclef.
- People reaching out to me.
- Just random?
- [Gary] Yes, Fredrik from the
real estate show wants to be on
the show, I know who he is,
I do well with real estate
agents so I'm like okay.
Fat Joe, fuck yeah, you
know so super duper random.
No real strategy other than we
have famous people to show you
market against their fan base on
platforms it brings awareness to
me it's interesting content I
needed a period of mixing it up.
It was just me now I don't want
any fucking guests ever again.
I'm back to wanting
to me and so that's.
I'm a counterpuncher by nature.
I have one core strategy where
is attention that most people
are underestimating?
Musical.ly I want every 8 to
15-year-old kid in America to
look up to me as the
entrepreneur for them so
if I get them at eight and seven
and nine, I'll have them.
So while everybody's like
Musical.ly's stupid I'm like
that's great but every first to
fifth-grader in America lives on
it and here comes old man Gary
as their favorite entrepreneur.
(audience laughter)
Got it?
- Let me throw
this at you though,
just as a little bounce back.
- [Gary] Let's do a bounce back.
- I like that.
So you're saying you mix it up,
how do you mix it up when you're
also trying to keep your head
in the game and just do that one
thing really, really well?
- Talent.
- [Rachel] Well, I'm
fucking talented I got that.
- Show me.
- [Rachel] Watch me.
Thank you.
- I'll see.
- [Rachel] Alright.
- Because you know the
best part about talent?
- [Rachel] Yes.
- Is we can all talk shit,
but results are fucking game.
- [Rachel] Okay, what you, how
are you measuring those results?
- Money.
(audience laughter)
Freedom, happiness.
- [Rachel] Okay.
- Money, happy, freedom
you know I don't know.
How many selfies I take a day?
I don't know.
I think we get to all
measure it differently, right?
- [Rachel] Right.
- And so, you know how many
people in here are all about
math, conversions and quant.
You know that's called?
That's called salespeople.
Marketing and branding doesn't
fucking get measured
by the hour.
- [Rachel] Alright, thank you.
- So for me how do I measure it
is how do I feel about
where I'm positioned.
How am I how am I equally,
VaynerMedia's gonna do
$100 million in revenue
this year and it's scaled.
It's not the
Gary Vaynerchuk consulting firm.
I don't fuckin'
deal with any clients.
I'm the CEO.
I hire people I do all my stuff
some of you seen the last
couple episodes, I'm
dealing with my HR stuff.
I'm running a company.
I run $100 million Madison
Avenue agency and in parallel
GaryVee is my side hustle.
You want to feel real bad
(audience laughter)
I'm an entrepreneur,
CEO of an agency.
I run an actual business so
for me how do I measure it?
How well is Vayner doing?
Right, how well is my
speaking request coming in?
How many people are watching my
stuff but I don't measure it on
a tactical day-to-day.
It's an overall feeling of
a vibe, intuition and some
baseline metrics that, I never
look at any of my data like
I can see it publicly I can see
if 10,000 people
liked this photo.
I'm like, "Oh shit, people
like this Instagram photo."
I'll look at it and
be like I don't know.
Seems like the same
old shit but anyway.
I think a lot of people are so
into landing page optimization,
by the way, that shit works
but that sales and
when you're great, brand.
They didn't cookie me and then
retarget me and then get me on a
list and then convert and
A/B test me and
funnel me and then
go make a deal with another
company and JV their lists for
each other and all
that fucking horse shit.
They branded me.
People didn't come here just to
see me speak because I cookied
them and ran a Facebook ad.
It's 'cause I provided so much
fucking value they wanted to see
it in person. Branding.
- [Rachel] Thank you.
(applause)
- Hi, I'm Gene.
I don't think you suffer from
this based on what we can see
about you in the real world--
- [Gary] You could be surprised.
- I could be surprised.
I've been working on this
concept around book
for a little while.
- [Gary] Around what?
- A book.
- You want to write a book.
- Yeah, I'm writing it.
- You're writing book.
- I actually will
finish the book--
- You finished the book.
- Back up.
- Okay.
- Mr. Hustle, I will
finish the book--
- One day.
(audience laughter)
- July 31st first draft.
- [Gary] Okay.
- I got more things
to do after that.
So the concept is I've been,
I go to live
events all the time.
I speak on stages, got a podcast
interviewing hundreds of people
it's called the trap of success.
- The trap of success?
- Yeah because there's a point
at which people get in success
and they play safe.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- You talked a little bit about
significance and about some of
the stuff that you do and the
book is really centered
around that.
I'd love your perspective on
that and what you see in your
circles 'cause you
interact with so many people.
- Around the notion of--
- [Man 3] When you stop?
- golden handcuffs versus--
- It could be golden handcuffs.
It's my personal story, part
of it, because I had a very
successful business and
I wanted to innovate I was
making $500,000 a year or
something like that.
And I had lifestyle and I said
I don't want to lose that--
- [Gary] Yeah, I get it.
- to go really make something
that wouldn't change my life and
change the life
of everyone else.
I played fucking safe--
- [Gary] Yep.
- because I was
afraid to it all.
- [Gary] That's right.
- And you can probably
guess what happened.
- Yeah, I mean it's not fun.
It's the same old story,
I think that we all
go through journeys.
One thing that I would tell you,
it's funny where my head went
when you started talking.
I think a lot about regret.
I think one of the most
interesting thing about spending
time with old people is regret.
If you talk to 80 and
90-year-olds the place where
their face really changes is
when they talk about what they
didn't do or what they wished
they did and here's the punch
line when you get to that age
and you're in a retirement home
or you're not moving
it's over and you know it.
A lot of us still live on we can
still, everything we're upset
about right now the majority
of us 99% of us can still do
something about it and
that hope drives us.
So you know, it's interesting.
It's really
interesting question.
You're right, I'm a little weird
I'm a little weird I don't know
if you ever caught this, I don't
talk about it often, I weirdly
fantasize of losing everything.
As a good thing.
- [Man 3] I actually heard you
say I wish I would because
I can build it back.
- To me, I love the build.
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- I think the reason I started
VaynerSports, this sports agency
is 'cause everybody thinks
it's a joke that is like
Drew Rosenhaus and CAA and
Rock Nation and I'm gonna
fucking slice their throats.
Right?
To me, I love that.
I love the underdog.
I hated Tiger Woods then
America started hating on him,
now I like him.
'Cause he's finished.
I hated Kobe but then we
got old I'm like oh yeah,
Kobe so I love the underdog.
I love the climb so for me
I'm very reverse like I love my
vacations before I get there.
The second I land on the plane
I start getting upset, right?
I live for anticipation and the
climb so I don't think I'm the
best person to give advice
around golden handcuffs.
I'm only comfortable putting
the chips in, changing it--
- [Man 3] But what do
you see from others?
- What's that?
- [Man 3] What do
you see from others?
- I see from others
people thinking short term.
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- Do you know how
long you're gonna live?
When I hear 35-year-olds tell
me their golden handcuffed
I'm like, "What
you're talking about?"
And it goes back to the lovely
lady that was right before you.
People want stuff.
You know your lifestyle
what was that, right?
Is it the house?
Is it the country club?
Is it the car?
Is it the trips?
- [Man 3] It was all of it.
- Yeah.
It's all of it.
So what I see in others you know
the answers, I don't need to
pontificate on it.
I'm just grateful and
thankful that I don't have it.
And I always wonder how much
of that has to do with the same
thing I started this with which
is I definitely don't
need it for others.
I think one of the things that
fascinating me in others is they
need the car and the watch
and the trophy husband or wife
because they want
other people to see it.
I mean this is why I pound
everybody to love
themselves first.
I don't need that.
I don't want that.
I don't care.
I love it.
It's fine, I like the accolades.
I like the attention.
I like the attention
because of what I put out.
I like that people take selfies
with me not because I score
41 points a night in arena but
because I'm putting out so much
good content that brings
them value they're thankful.
So when I think about
significance I think about all
the money I leave on the table
every day to do the
GaryVee side hustle thing.
You know, my other billionaire
friends that build businesses
always are weirded out by me.
They're like why are you
wasting your time with that?
And I'm like part of its vanity.
I like the admiration but I
tell them all the time I'm like,
"Look, yeah you may end up 940
million and I may end up with
"297 million but a lot more
"people are gonna show
up at my funeral.
"A lot more people like me.
"A lot more people are gonna say
nice things about me to my kids
"than they are about you and
that's more important to me."
- Yeah.
I'll tell you the reason you
said a word there I hadn't
thought of 'cause it's
helped me with the book--
- [Gary] A little louder.
- You said regret.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And I hadn't thought about
this but the reason I'm writing
the book is because
of my own regret.
- [Gary] Yep.
- And it's because I had that
chance to do something big.
- [Gary] Yep.
- And I fucked it off.
- Here's the coolest
part, bro, how old are you?
- 45.
- [Gary] You have a
fuck load more at-bats.
- I will never retire.
- That's fine.
You do 87 more big things.
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- You may save somebody from
getting hit by a truck
in four years.
There's so much to be done.
Little and big, you know?
- [Man 3] But the reason I'm
writing is because the regret
and I'm helping him with my
business now I'm helping people
see what I didn't see.
- I get it.
- [Man 3] And so that they
can build that business,
they can take that--
- I get it.
- [Man 3] that chance--
- [Man 3] build that huge thing.
- I understand.
- [Man 3] And get out of
their own fucking way.
- Agree.
- [Man 3] Get uncomfortable.
- Yep.
- [Man 3] and invest in
themselves all that, all that
shit so thanks for
your perspective.
- You got it.
Understood.
(applause)
My man.
Alright, I'm gonna start
going a little faster.
- [Man 4] Sure.
Gary-mother-fuckin-Vee.
What is up, dude?
- [Gary] What's up, man?
- Dude, this is so amazing.
I've been following you for you
actually that USC video that you
did that like just took off.
I'm sure you know that.
- [Gary] Yes.
- That actually is what
got me up on you man.
It's been fantastic.
I've been an
entrepreneurs since 2006.
I'm a coffee guy.
I do coffee.
I know you like coffee.
- Yep.
- [Man 4] Rock 'n roll, roasters
coffee in case anybody cares.
I'm sure some of you guys do.
But anyways, I started in
2009 and I opened my first shop,
brick-and-mortar, I have a seven
locations now and it
wasn't easy right?
2008, 2009, 2010 man I bought a
coffee roaster on Craigslist.
It was like for pennies because
everybody was selling everything
for cheap and it was hard.
It was hard, a lot of anxiety,
a lot of you know
bankruptcy was looming.
It was crazy, it was
intense, it was difficult.
Those first few
years were insane.
Nowadays it's almost too easy
to be an entrepreneur, right?
- [Gary] Yep.
- It's almost too easy.
- [Gary] It's not easy.
Are you talking about
people getting funding?
They're gonna lose.
- [Man 4] Exactly.
- My man, real quick,
it's easy to say
you're an entrepreneur.
- [Man 4] Yeah.
- Is it easy to be a
successful entrepreneur?
- [Man 4] For sure.
- It's not.
- Right, so the question is then
what you see happening in the
next one, two, three years down
the road? Because right now the
last seven years
man it's been up.
What do you see
happening though?
- [Gary] I don't know because
what you're asking is when does
the economy shift and that
has a lot more to do with those
characters on Wall Street are up
to shenanigans and whenever the
shit falls out
from underneath it.
I don't know but here's what
I can tell you, the world is
proven to us a whole bunch of
times that goes up and it
goes down, right?
- [Man 4] Right.
- I just don't know the timing
and I think if you're asking
with the purpose of I want to be
prepared I think I live my life
that I'm prepared for shit
to hit the wall every day.
Every day I anticipate that
I'm gonna wake up and it's
Armageddon.
- [Man 4] I love it.
- And so, I would tell you if
I understand where the energy's
coming from never overextend
yourself and hold your breath
that shit's gonna still be good
for a year because not me,
not anybody's gonna
answer that for you.
What you need to do is make
pretend tomorrow everything is
gonna be fucked and are you able
to take that punch in the mouth?
It's funny, my favorite scene in
every movie is that part where
that person gets punched in the
mouth and they spit their tooth
out and then look
back at the person.
I love that moment 'cause
that's who I think I am
as an entrepreneur.
I want bad.
I'll be very honest with you,
I hope it comes tomorrow.
Because the quicker it happens,
the quicker all you fake
entrepreneurs are gonna get
the fuck out of this game.
(applause)
- [Man 4] Thank you
man, that's perfect.
- Got it.
- [Sean] Hey guys, in an effort
to get through as many questions
as possible if we can keep some
of the back story to a minimum,
just ask the question for Gary
we'd love to hear the answer if
you can get to the question.
That'd be great.
- Hey Gary, I'm Jeremy.
- [Gary] Hey man.
- I had a question for you about
with the advent of social media
and the way things have really
changed, there seems to be this
trend now where everybody even
if they have no value to offer
is an entrepreneur.
- [Gary] That's right.
- What pisses you off the
most in that current trend?
- [Gary] What
pisses me off what?
- What pisses you off the
most about that current trend?
- I just feel bad for people.
I feel bad.
It pisses me off in a weird
way but since you asked me what
pisses me off,
I'm gonna go the other way.
I'm empathetic and I feel really
bad for all the people that are
writing $25,000 checks and
are gonna lose that money.
They fought hard to get it and
they're putting it into some kid
'cause they thinks they're the
next Mark Zuckerberg and
they're gonna get fucked.
I feel bad for a bunch of
kids that been told that
entrepreneurship is cool and
they want to be in it where they
could have went and worked at a
law firm or worked at Bain and
McKinsey and made a lot of money
and were naturally themselves.
You know how much more money
number 13 made at Facebook than
number one of Smaschbook?
What upsets me is that the
narrative is that it's so easy.
Back to the last
question and that guy, right?
It's easy to say
you're a founder.
It's a lot harder to do it five
years from today and so
I'm more worried
than I am pissed off.
I'm worried about suicide.
There's a rise in depression
and suicide in entrepreneur land
because for some reason
everybody thinks that you are
successful when you start a
business and you have a lot of
Ivy League school kids who've
always had a vigged
game of success.
You know I always say daddy
can't buy a library
in the market.
The market, the business world,
can't be bought and so we've got
a lot of people going into
entrepreneurship that aren't
wired for it and their outlet
to fix it is quite negative.
Sometimes the most extreme.
Penn, a great school with a lot
of entrepreneurial DNAs has seen
a significant rise in suicide
and it's predicated on everybody
thinking that they're gonna be
Travis or Zucks so I'm worried
more for people than I
am pissed for the game of
entrepreneurship. You know?
- [Man 5] And there seems and
I talked with this a lot on my
podcast, there seems to be this
missing link between when they
start and when
they got successful.
They leave out all
the negative shit
and just go from I started
here, here's all the money.
- Yeah, it's why I always
like talking about hustle.
Everyone's like ugh.
People love to at conferences
I'm at or when a use my name
to get traffic
for their website.
They're like no you
don't have to do that.
You can do it so awesome and
passive income (blows raspberry)
and all that shit so
it's fuckin' very hard.
Guys, do you know what the top
1% of earners in America what
the bottom number is
of the top 1% earner,
the entry point into the 1%?
It's $400,000.
If you make, if you're sitting
here and you make $400,000 or
more, you're in the
1% earners in America.
Do you know how
outrageously successful that is?
But some people that don't make
1 million a year are
like oh I'm not good.
It's crazy the way
we've built up this game.
It's crazy.
We need to reframe
entrepreneurship.
Entrepreneurship to me is you
can't breathe doing
anything else.
There was no work, even that
last guy, I love that guy 'cause
he's giving me a lot of love
and he had a great vibe.
I love when he said I've been an
entrepreneur since '06 and when
he said that I said in my
mind either you're not an
entrepreneur or you were an
entrepreneur from the get.
It's binary.
Entrepreneurship
is not a profession,
it's what you are, you know?
So yeah.
- [Man 5] Thank you.
- You got it.
My man with the kicks.
- Yeah.
Hey Gary, Kevin Stephson here.
I own a branding and
creative boutique.
- [Gary] Great.
- And so we're all about
creating memorable, disruptive
and bad ass brands.
- [Gary] Okay.
- And the one thing that I stand
against is that most online
businesses can care less about
being memorable,
disruptive and bad ass.
They want to do the same
exact thing as everybody else.
They value clicks and all that.
- Yes.
- [Kevin] What I wonder is
I want to hear how you would
communicate the ROI of a brand
and what that means to you.
- You mean the biggest
companies in the world?
- [Kevin] Yes.
Or anybody what is that ROI?
- More money.
It's why I don't talk about
conversion and landing page
optimization and email
conversion and funnels and shit
like 'cause there's plenty of
people talking about sales.
I talk about brand.
Branding is putting
out the best story,
putting out content
that brings value.
Brand is you can't explain it
but you know it when you see it.
Right and so I always tell
people Apple is a
terrible advertiser.
They're just a
great fuckin' brand. Right?
I love when homies in this world
and most of the people here are
converters and math and quant
when they talk shit about the
biggest brands in
the world doing bad.
You know they're like oh look
how silly that ad is or they
didn't do their SEO proper.
I'm like Rick do you
understand you're talking about?
Yes, all of us are not as strong
at every tactic but how do
I describe brand and what it
means, I explained it by listing
the 500 biggest companies in the
world, the coolest people in the
world, the people that are
winning and the companies that
are winning and I talk about
brand and then I talk about
things that have lost because
they were conversion based
machines, Zynga, Living Social.
There's people that are way
better at math than you are and
so if marketing was math my
friends this shit would have
been over a long time ago.
Now, I don't want to
disrespect the math.
We live in a digital age where
the math and the conversion,
the landing page
optimization it matters.
But if you don't layer something
pure and good or awesome or what
you're talking on top of it you
can only hit a certain level.
And that's okay.
You know how many people here
don't give a fuck about you and
I talk about brand are pumped
to make their million dollars a
year on quant conversion,
landing page optimization.
The problem is here's why
brand's awesome, when brand
converts from desktop landing
page optimization to a
mobile device, brand goes there.
The people here that lived and
died on that conversion lose.
When Google changes algorithm,
right, brand survives.
People that did
SEO farming lost.
Got it?
When this all goes to
VR brand's coming.
But you're gonna have to figure
out how to survive when we don't
have have clicks and conversions
and it's all
virtual in 10 years.
All of you ready for 10 years
from now when it's gonna be
brand not conversion
based SEO and quant magic?
That's brand.
- [Kevin] Mic drop.
(applause)
- By the way that was a
really important part
of this conference.
If you're relying on internet
marketing arbitrage you need to
be prepared for the next decade
because a lot of transformations
are coming and you don't want to
be one-dimensional just relying
on that one arbitrage, on that
JV, on that landing page,
on that Facebook ads,
on that SEM strategy
you've got to
be prepared.
- [Munchy] Hi Gary,
my name is Munchy.
- Munchy, how are you?
- [Munchy] Great.
- Closer to the mic,
closer to the mic.
- I love you and you're a
role mode of mine because of
how authentic you are.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
- The most important thing to me
which is why I love you because
you always preach it is loving
yourself so I know if I love
myself truthfully I'll be a
better businessman,
better person, better--
- [Gary] 100%.
- So I work on that a lot and my
question to you is some tips on
how I can do that
better or more.
Sometimes I do it amazing,
sometimes I'm struggling.
- Keep the people that say good
things about you close, back to
the first question today, I'll
be honest with you, it's very
interesting in the way
I'm going about it, right?
My mom did it for me, now I'm
having you guys do it for me.
I read the good shit, you know,
how many of you have heard me
say, "Your comments are my
oxygen," raise your hand?
That's it.
- Great friends.
I surround myself
with great friends.
- [Gary] That's it, man.
Listen, we're all
gonna have down days.
You just try to make more good
ones than bad ones but having a
community and re-read
nice things about you.
The reason I love giving you so
much is when you email me back
and say nice things or you give
me good energy, I need that.
That's my oxygen so I have to
stay positive and the other
thing is I cut negativity out.
The reason, so a lot of you, how
many of you have seen the last
two DailyVees where I've being
doing the culture
thing quite a bit?
It's funny a lot of you have
been, wait a minute, a lot of
you are not watching it.
Fuck, that sucked.
(audience laughter)
A lot of people have
been hitting me up
and going, "Gary I can help
you with all your problems."
They don't realize our
culture is phenomenal.
Jared you were in the
office the other day.
It's fucking happy land.
It's just I have fucking such a
high standard that I want zero
cynicism and negativity so
I just continue to cut
that cancer out.
- [Munchy] I think it's
coming from myself--
- Well that was
instilled in you brother.
- [Munch] Yeah, it was.
So how do I beat
the shit out it?
- By cutting more of it
out and adding more good in.
Every day I'm doing this, every
day I'm fucking doing this.
I'm pushing anything negative
out and I'm bringing everything
good in, every day and every
day I'm getting fucking, got it?
That's it.
The shit that went in you in the
get you got to get that out by
what you do now.
You can't dwell
that it got there.
You know how many people
are losing 'cause you dwell?
My friends, stop
fucking dwelling.
Nobody gives a shit.
You can't dwell.
I'm sorry that grew up
in a bad neighborhood.
I'm sorry that
you're a minority.
I'm sorry that this
bad thing happened.
Nobody gives a fuck so cut your
dwelling hours and
start looking at good.
Let me give you on
really great thing.
You're a human being.
Do you know how
fucking insane that is?
For all you math fuckin' nerds,
look at that fuckin' math.
It's hard and so
that's what you have to do.
- [Munchy] Thank you.
- You got it.
(applause)
- Hi Gary.
- [Gary] Hey.
- My name is Tela.
Speaking of Wall Street from
earlier, I teach people how to
create an income in the stock
market and build financially so
they can quit their 9-to-5s.
When I look at this industry
there's such a
negative stigma on it.
- Yes, like I hate Wall
Street more than Hitler.
- [Tela] I do too.
But what is your advice for
getting past that stigma
to my audience and also--
- Tell the people in Wall
Street to stop fucking around.
You're not gonna be able to
get them past that stigma.
- [Tela] Yeah.
- I know 50 guys and gals on
Wall Street right now who are
telling me to my face that
they're doing the dirty business
that they did that
knocked it down before.
- [Tela] I teach them to
do this for themselves.
Don't give your
fuckin' money to Gary,--
- Yeah, but the problem is the
people that are fuckin' vigging
the game, when their shit hits
the fan all your people that did
it nice by themselves are gonna
get fucked when the
market gets cut in half.
- [Tela] Depending
on how you do it.
- Respect.
- [Tela] Depending
upon the system.
- Here's what I know 100% of the
people who lose when the market
loses 50% of it's net
worth overnight, right?
When you those, the only thing
that happens and you know this,
I know you know this, if you
look at the patterns over the
last two decades you know
exactly what happens next.
These markets are naturally,
fakely being inflated which is
why they're gonna
have dramatic drops.
- [Tela] And that's why you
learn to trade put options.
If you're making
money on the down.
- Listen, respect
and you can short.
I understand how you
can bet against it,--
- [Tela] Right.
- But what I would say to you
is, what I always tell people is
is there's no marketing in the
world, people come to me all the
time and I go look if I am or
if I was or if I aspire to be
there's no great marketing
that fixes a shit product.
Right?
- [Tela] Yeah.
- So how do you get people to
stop looking at the the
market negatively?
You won't because the
narrative will stay there.
What you can do is educate them
and this is really a very big
point, you need to
change the script.
You need to tell them that
people looking at the market in
a negative way is
the opportunity.
- [Tela] Okay.
- Do you see where I'm going?
- [Tela] Yes.
- The fact that smart guys like
me don't want to fuck around
with it is their opportunity.
- Okay and how do I get past
the, when I look out there at
others that are in the industry
I see the stacks of cash, and
the half naked ladies and the
yachts and that's not what,
that's not the picture
I'm trying to paint.
- [Gary] So don't paint it.
- [Tela] But that's what?
- You're talking to me.
I fucking hate every single
person that's in marketing with
their bullshit, fuck, I don't
even want to get into this.
The Instagram culture of
this horse shit is the worst.
I just, you know, I hate it
but I navigate through it.
You're not gonna stop people
selling people the
bullshit dream.
- [Tela] Yeah.
- What you need to is
be an anomaly within it.
- [Tela] Okay.
- Alright?
- [Tela] Alright.
- Awesome.
- [Tela] Thank you.
- You got it.
(applause)
- [Colin] Hey Gary,
Colin Layman.
In episodes 202 of
The Show I asked you
how long you took to
celebrate your win of crushing
this last book launch
and your answer was none.
- Right.
- [Colin] You said you
suck at celebrating.
- I do.
- [Colin] Then you
pontificated on that you
actually need to do more of it.
- Yes.
- [Colin] I'm just super curious
if you have since thought of
that and if you're, where you're
going with your celebration
because that sounds like that
you realize it's something
that you need to do.
- Yep.
So since that episode,
I remember that very clearly,
I've done nothing good.
(audience laughter)
I've celebrated
nothing and I haven't
been able to move
the needle whatsoever.
(audience laughter)
- [Colin] Awesome.
- Great.
- [Colin] What are you
gonna do to fix that?
- It's in the same way,
it's back to the talent
conversation, right?
It's like there's certain things
that are hardwired in us and
I'd like to be better at it.
It seems fun to celebrate,
I just am more
comfortable in the climb.
- [Colin] That's one
thing I wondered after.
Is it that you need to
celebrate, is that honestly you
think you need to
learn how to do or is this--
- Yeah.
- [Colin] the celebration?
- Yeah, I think you got it.
I think the way it, the whole
thing is the celebration for me.
You know what I mean?
- [Colin] Yeah.
- I'm just so grateful.
Guys, for all of you like to
have people admire you enough to
want to take a picture with you
or sit here and listen to you
like I wish you and I have a
feeling a lot of you have this
and we all have
different versions of it.
Plenty people have more than
me, plenty of people have less.
The feeling that other human
being value what comes out of
your mouth and
like you so intense.
There's no dollar amount.
If I don't make another dollar
in my life I already made a fuck
load of money.
The money is great and I want it
and do I want to buy the Jets?
Of course.
If you know me best you know
I want to try to buy the Jets.
That's the part
that is my drive.
I made a video already, I'll
share it here, there's a video
of me that I will share with the
world that proclaims that this
day is the worst day of my life
and I'm gonna run it
the day I buy the Jets.
Because then that part is over
and I'm glad I made such
a lofty goal, you know?
How many of you and don't
bullshit this is a very
interesting insight and it's not
pro or con so don't be scared
but I want to see the number.
How many of you have already
surpassed the financial or
success goal you had for
yourself in your kind of
teenage early years?
Raise your hand.
I figured it's gonna be a lot.
That's awesome and that's
fucking the best, right?
The way I'm wired, I'm so
grateful that I made, even
subconsciously in
fourth grade, I knew myself.
I made something so fuckin'
big that I get to play every day
even in my monstrous
success so I think you got it.
- [Colin] Thank you.
- Thanks, brother.
One more I'll sneak
in, I see the time.
(applause)
One more.
This guy gets it.
- So Gary, read Crush It! in
2009, thank you so much.
Built a full time income on
YouTube and I love doing that
but I'm super passionate about
speaking, doing podcasts like
you're talking
about speaking invites.
I think that adds a lot
of value to people here.
What are your tactics if that's
what you want
to transition in to?
Teaching the how of how
you did it and speaking.
- So what are the tactics if you
want to transition into
getting paid to speak?
- [Man 6] Correct.
- Speak for free a lot.
- [Man 6] Awesome.
Thank you.
- And that's it.
Do you know what I did in 2006?
I found a site, I think it was
Techmeme at the time that had a
list of all the
conferences, right?
And I just went to the websites
of all those conferences and
I emailed them and
said I'd like to speak.
And most of them said,
"Who the fuck are you?"
(audience laughter)
And I said,
"You're worse than,"
no, no, I don't know.
Me, this is me,right?
The number one thing you
should do is speak for free.
So many people are fancy,
my friend, so many
people are fancy.
You want something,
fight for it.
Best way you can fight for it,
is go around and do it for free,
build up a resume, put those
talks on your website,
build momentum.
I had no clue that I was
a good public speaker.
I was 32-years-old first
time I ever gave a talk.
Had no clue.
You may be great at it.
If you're doing YouTube
full time, you might have that
storytelling so just do as many
gigs for free as possible and
never say no for the event.
I'll leave with this, I know
it's time to go, never say no
for the other person.
One of the biggest mistakes that
a lot of people make here and
have left a lot of opportunity
on the table is you think that
if you were running that event
you wouldn't say yes to you thus
you don't ask.
Never say no.
So go down the list of the 50
events, hit him up,
I want to talk, no dude.
Cool, go to there, no.
Go to there, yes.
Boom, you just got something
bigger than you thought.
Got it?
- [Man 6] Love it, thank you.
- But also be ghetto and be
willing to do the Chamber of
fucking Commerce event three
minutes from your house with
nine fucking grandmas in it.
- [Man 6] Yeah.
(audience laughter
and applause)
- Thank you, guys.
(applause)